por fin un juicio en la audiencia
empleados de charlie hebdo y las
familias de los fallecidos mientras se
leen los cargos una mujer sale de la
sala llorando la madre de sap uno de los
dibujantes que fue asesinado a tiros
hace cinco años es escoltada por uno de
los antiguos colegas de su hijo y para
mí no querías venir hoy que te hizo
cambiar de opinión en tenis
siempre se trata de los que fueron
asesinados hubiera querido que fuéramos
lo suficientemente valientes para tomar
una posición aquí hoy tenemos que ser
valientes para fue al cual también
asistió la sanaba chilli un empleado de
limpiar que hay en el supermercado que
fue asaltado después de la sede de la
revista es uno de los 200 demandantes en
el juicio ha esperado años para
enfrentarse a los acusados y exige
respuestas es difícil mirarlos a la cara
ya sea que se trate de los acusados o en
los verdaderos tiradores todos son
iguales para mí los pongo a todos en la
misma cesta
pero si los once sospechosos de ser
cómplices presentes el miércoles tendrán
que responder ante el juez lo más
probable es que nieguen que sabían algo
del compló de terror nada de eso habría
ocurrido y no habría oído todo este
sufrimiento si los servicios de
inteligencia hubieran madre de ellos su
vigilancia sobre los hermanos cuasi y
américo olivari 17 personas murieron a
manos de los tres llega distas antes de
ser asesinados por la policía saliendo
que perdió 12 vidas rédito esta semana
las controvertidas caricaturas del
profeta mahoma que los pistoleros
citaron como su motivación
ese es el espíritu de charly et o
negarse a renunciar a nuestras
libertades nuestro derecho a reír y
criticar y nuestra libertad de blasfemar
porque si renunciamos a ellas dejaremos
un oscuro futuro para nuestros hijos
las primeras semanas del juicio se
dedicarán a escuchar los testimonios de
los demandantes y los testigos pasará
algún tiempo antes de que los acusados
hablen en el tribunal